how did Universal Studios know that this
is what the world looked like especially
from space okay let's be clear we
we had Globes well before we went to
space like here's a globe from the 1400s
not super accurate but we had a globe
but then look at this these Beauties are
from 1862 well before we went to space
it's from a French Atlas that I'd like
to just look at because it's freaking
gorgeous but I mean look at the detail
this looks like the Earth well before we
saw it from space
the fact is we knew what the Earth
looked like because of a lot of math and
measurements and we were able to put
that
onto a sphere using this thing called
projection and it was all mathy and cool
but yeah we didn't need to go to space
to do all this we just had math and a
bunch of smart people working on this
and that's how we did it